didier sapy il est directeur de la
fédération nationale avenir et qualité
de vie des personnes âgées didier sapy
bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur rt france alors les épate ce sont
des confiné mais de nouvelles
restrictions sont peu à peu imposée
manuel macron je le disais ne souhaite
pas confiné à nouveau les plus
vulnérables mais il les appelle à
redoubler de vigilance cela veut dire
quoi très concrètement c'est moins de
visites
ce sont des visites peut-être plus
réglementée avec beaucoup plus deux avec
plus de précaution mais dans certains
cas seulement je crois qu'il faut pas
totalement dramatiser la situation dans
nos établissements
il ya aujourd'hui 121 établissements en
france qui sont touchés avant ça peut
paraître beaucoup comme ça mais je
rappelle qu'il ya 7000 près de 7500
établissement c'est à cannes à 1,5 pour
cent aujourd'hui qui sont touchés
l'objectif c'est de protéger et de
préserver tous ceux qui ne le sont pas
donc c'est une ce sont ces précautions
là qu'il convient de prendre il faut que
les familles dont on a besoin dans nos
établissements auprès de leurs parents
auprès de nos personnes âgées
comprennent fassent preuve de
compréhension et d'esprit de
responsabilité par rapport à ça et
accepte un certain nombre de règles de
précaution dans un certain nombre de cas
parce que ces vagues durant le
confinement et aujourd'hui on avait en
tête en cette volonté de bunkérisation
ces lieux là c'est pas la bonne solution
vaut nous dit aujourd'hui
ah non surtout pas le président de la
république a raison il sale impact
considérable sur la vie des gens ça y
est la qualité de vie des personnes
âgées leur lors les interactions
sociales qu'elles peuvent avoir
l'isolément le risque d'isolement serait
catastrophique isolement de leur famille
et de toutes leurs relations sociales on
a vu dans un certain nombre de cas des
situations difficiles c'est très
difficile à vivre pour ces personnes qui
ont encore ces familles qui ont encore
ses relations sociales et qu'elles
doivent qu'elles doivent développer
jusqu'au bout bien entendu donc c'est
extrêmement important de ne pas isoler
ces personnes une deuxième vague serait
serait totalement catastrophique bien
entendu et on est confronté bien sûr à
ce dilemme permanent entre protéger nos
résidents protéger les personnes qui
vivent dans nos établissements et les
accompagner au mieux dans leur qualité
de vie dans les derniers mois une
dernière année de leur vie bien entendu
et en ce qui concerne la la réactivité
dans les ehpad face par exemple à une
suspicion de 4 coronavirus comment
est-ce que ça se passait ce que les
campagnes de dépistage au sein de ces
établissements sont fréquentes
est-ce qu'il ya moins de délais pour
avoir des résultats alors non être vrai
point clé aujourd'hui ce sont ce sont
les tests la réactivité en cas
d'organisation dans les établissements
d'agilité de mise en place d'un certain
nombre de mesures organisationnelles
d'appels à des équipes mobiles avec la
coopération des services de l'état tout
ça fonctionne son fonctionnent plutôt
bien sur le territoire
la grosse difficulté ce sont les tests
ce que nous demandons aujourd'hui au
ministère un aux pouvoirs publics c'est
d'organiser mieux ces tests et dès que
nous avons un cadeau qu'ovide suspicieux
ou avérées dans nos établissements
il faut impérativement qu'il ya des
équipes mobiles qui viennent dans les
établissements pour tester tous les
résidents tous les salariés dans les 24
heures avec des résultats des tests dans
les 24 heures
ça c'est absolument c'est la priorité
absolue par rapport à ces mesures de
précaution justement aujourd'hui c'est
pas pensable d'attendre sept jours ou
neuf jours des résultats de tests avant
de pouvoir prendre des mesures
organisationnelles
la direction de l'établissement doit
savoir le plus vite possible ce qu'il en
est parmi les résidents des ehpad quel
est le moral aujourd'hui quelle est
l'atmosphère et au sein des personnels
aussi comment vont-ils on peut rappeler
qu'il veille sur les personnes âgées
depuis plus de six mois maintenant vous
savez sur les personnes âgées elles
mêmes elles sont plus de 600 milles à
vivre dans nos établissements et c'est
difficile de savoir comment elles vont
tout parce que vous
six cent mille situations différentes et
les gens vivent les choses de manière
extrêmement différentes
alors pour les salariés je peux
peut-être plus en parler on a peut-être
plus de retour il est vrai aujourd'hui
qu'on a des vraies difficultés au niveau
des ressources humaines parce que les
salariés ont vécu cette vague ont fait
face avec énormément de courage et
d'agilité je le disais et aujourd'hui
elles sont fatiguées elles ont passé
l'été les vacances ont pas été si facile
que ça on est dans cette situation de
risque permanent on sait que ça va durer
plusieurs mois
il ya de la peur il ya des craintes il
ya de la fatigue on a des absences aussi
parce qu'à la moindre suspicion de covin
il faut isoler les gens c'est difficile
on peut pas laisser des professionnels
intervenir auprès de personnes
extrêmement fragile sans être sûr
qu'elles sont en bonne santé
donc tout ça génère aussi des
difficultés de remplacements des
sous-effectifs on a besoin d'être aidé
là aussi par les pouvoirs publics
d'avoir plus de bras plus de ressources
humaines à très court terme dans nos
établissements
didier sapy pour conclure en quelques
mots emmanuel macron a indiqué que son
objectif était de présenter dès le début
de l'année prochaine un projet de loi
sur le grand âge et l'économie lors de
sa visite à cet après midi dans un ehpad
du loir et cher
qu'est ce que vous en attendez mais est
où on en attend tout ça fait ça fait
deux ans maintenant qu'il l'a annoncé il
l'avait annoncé en juin 2018 pour fin
2010 9
ça fait plusieurs mois qu'on nous
l'annoncent pour fin 2020 on craignait
que il nous annonce un report même d'un
an supplémentaire donc c'est plutôt
rassurant qu'il annonce une autre autre
loin au début de l'année 2000 21
c'est très attendu maintenant
il suffit pas de le dire il faut le
faire il faut vraiment qu'ils le fassent
ça fait des années ça fait des années
qu'on attend ça fait des années que nous
avons des dizaines et des dizaines de
rapports
ce sera la loi l'a probablement la plus
documentée du quinquennat maintenant il
faut agir
on attend de lui qu'il agisse et pas
seulement qu'il le dise maintenant il
faut qu'il le fasse
merci beaucoup didier sapy d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes directeur de la fnac passé la
fédération nationale avenir et qualité
de vie des personnes âgées